In Crossville, Tennessee
God has his very own treehouse
God told Noah to build an ark
He told Horace Burgess to build a treehouse
God’s treehouse
In 1993 Minister Horace Burgess heard the word of God
and God said to him
“if you build a treehouse"
“you will never run out of materials”
which is kind of a pretty minimal promise
but Horace started building
piece by piece, out of scrap wood
and leftover building materials
supported by six different trees
mainly supported by one giant white oak
it’s 97 feet tall
or a better way to put that is ten stories tall
it took over 285,000 nails
when you walk into it, you have no idea where you are going to end up
this treehouse includes
secret hallways
some hidden rooms
spiral staircases
at the heart of this is the sanctuary
slash basketball court
slash dance floor
slash whatever else you need it to be
and when you get to the top
and you look down at the fields below
you will see the word Jesus written out in flowers
planted by Burgess
because as Burgess himself says
from up there the view is heavenly
so he spent the last 14 years crafting this incredible treehouse
but sadly, while God doesn’t have a fire code
Crossville, Tennessee does
in 2012 the Minister’s Treehous
the greatest treehouse ever built
was closed down
you can, in fact, call the Crossville, Tennessee fire marshall
and politely ask them
that they reopen the treehouse
and in Horace Burgess’s own words
It’s not for him
it’s for everybody and God keeps watch
the treehouse also inspires it’s visitors
one such visitor was so taken
that he went and created stained glass windows
which were then installed into the treehouse as well.
the bells of the treehouse
are a set of empty acetylene gas tanks
that have been strung up by rope
and when pulled chime together
in a kind of lo-fi DIY heavenly harmony